it's time for your Kardashian ketchup I
feel very blessed in an all-new teaser
for Sunday night's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians season finale we see how the
family reacted when Kris got into that
scary car crash back in August Sunday
the Kardashians season finale will shake
everyone where is mom I thought she was
gonna be here
your mom's just in the neck good at the
time crystal DT she was sore and shaken
but fine and she seems to be in good
spirits today too
Kris was hanging out with her family on
Monday night Kourtney Khloe and Rob all
documented their time together on
snapchat
oh are your time's running out Oh
Khloe also shared this pic from the day
she's back at to her waist training ways
it's not crazy oh and we got our first
look at Khloe's new weight-loss show
revenge body set to premiere next year
it's not about a wait number it's about
how you feel
Khloe gave me that great opportunity man
find that I can do something without
anybody else who can legitimately say
that their life was changed by a
Kardashian Rob's fiance blac Chyna was
seemingly at home working on her
post-baby body about to get his body
back right and Kylie Jenner was busy
giving fans a preview of her new Kylie
cosmetics holiday set I'm excited about
it
you